and right now my moment is bull riding
okay I hate that you think that's a
cowboy hat I'm a prisoner of the moment
I hate that you think
he looks like a Bushwick bull rider like
you get together with your friends on a
Thursday and you ride the mechanical
bull and you all [ __ ] do your stupid
[ __ ] ass artisanal shots or whatever at
the bar karaoke and then you take the L
train
and then you take the L train back home
it [ __ ] infuriates me bro he's got
his cowboy boots though wallabies
at least come with some cowboy boots I
did the best I [ __ ] could okay this
is the best Cowboy I Could Be Cowboys
okay remember where that cowboy was like
honey where are my corduroys you don't
think cowboys wear cornrows gotta go
protect the town my black quarter damn
it [ __ ] all of y'all okay I'm doing my
best you look like Rango that [ __ ]
frog
oh my God
this version of Toy Story would be so
much better wouldn't it if you were a
woody but he's just super gay yeah hey
Buzz listen
stop trying to make Disney gay bro
y'all are [ __ ] y'all need to embrace
bull riding bro y'all are jealous
because you weren't at the PBR I've been
to see bull riding bro you invited
everybody I grew up in Texas oh I grew
up in Texas
yeah you know one thing Texas bro stop
it you're from India you know India
that's actually a good point you grew up
in Texas but you chose up black okay
yeah exactly but that don't mean I
haven't been you haven't been you've
never seen no bull riding this is really
this is the most what happens in bull
riding go
yeah you describe that no what happens
in bull riding go I bet you don't know
yeah what's what's the story
what's the favorite floor yeah
or is there sacred flaw the thought that
they can control their surroundings wow
oh the writers think that they can
control their environment but the
reality is that it cannot control their
environment and the bull teaches them
that and they have to submit to the ball
they want to keep because you know that
this hand right here can't touch the
ball
you didn't even know that did not know
that the [ __ ] got disqualified
and the guy goes the guy was like why
the [ __ ] you off like he touched the
bullet and I go you can't touch the bull
how crazy is that that's crazy write it
don't touch it one ant whoa boom
son I can't believe it
or the baby the little cafe I didn't go
no [ __ ] [ __ ] like you go to bro they
ain't got no baby you only saw half of
it you only saw the bull riding you
didn't even see the whole thing bro you
actually see the whole thing this is
like going towards yeah right again
like this guy's crazy
let me tell you something lasso and all
that [ __ ] you guys all right you guys
you're bragging about like going to an
NBA game and you're bragging about like
the Asian lady to throw the balls on her
head now we saw the whole thing we just
made you probably left early yeah you
probably left early to buy that [ __ ]
ass hat probably yeah I came there with
the head on I got this shout out to my
boy Robin ramble Ryan ramble listen it's
a beautiful life
this is Ryan it's a gorgeous hat it's
just not a cowboy hat yeah that's the
cowboy person hat I think this is house
I'll be honest
this right here is the most straight I
mean it is the most straight that's what
I'm saying
no no no that curvy [ __ ] what they
wearing Brokeback Mountain that curvy
[ __ ] that's how you know they were
actual Cowboys because they were actual
Cowboys
[Laughter]
y'all first of all you not invited to
know PBR you're not inviting on PBR you
and I invited
here
Curious George your bike here is George
Curious George is a monkey bruh no
that's the guy yeah the owner or
whatever yeah literally oh where's his
name man yo what happened you know he
became a man
[Music]
I look like all white cartoons if you
look at all white cartoons I look like
all every single one of them five five
versus five every single one of them no
that was Dove remember when his face was
half and half okay look here's the
reality of the matter that bull riding
[ __ ] and I did go to the city PBR that
shout out to the PBR man which is just
bull riding he didn't go to a rodeo
half ass he doesn't understand this guy
knows nothing about it uh you grew up in
Texas don't even know the pbr's so uh
the PBR professional bull riding the
theme of the crop oh we couldn't figure
that out you clearly didn't know you
thought I was at the rodeo yeah
why would it have why would professional
bull riding have other [ __ ] Akash name
three rodeo events besides bull riding
the [ __ ] lasso with the calf wrong
yep yes it is wrong that is an event
that is wrong it's not called lasso and
it's called roping you're [ __ ] it's
Yankee thank you you're a Yankee he's
right it's called tie down roping it's
called roping another one I don't know
another one yeah what do you say
yeehawks Barrel Chase and then this I'm
not gonna sound very I'm gonna sound
like a big dork when I say this but
that's when I was like oh I'm more Hindu
than I am Texan because watching them
rope up the little baby cows I was like
I can't do this [ __ ] dude I gotta go I
gotta go dude I can't do it I'm a little
[ __ ] about it but I was like this
[ __ ] up man I can't be here well they
don't kill him I don't think they just
kind of time up yeah but it's [ __ ] up
to what you wouldn't know if you even
watch it but if you watch it like why am
I doing this man this little baby couch
trying to live dude Bogan Bogan poking
his ass with this hot ass thing it just
bothered me to do Hindu for it when they
do the Lambs you ever see what they do
the Lambs that wouldn't bother me as
much as they handle why it's a cow dude
cow's sacred see Lamb
to me I'm like they're both just living
their lives you know doing their thing
listen listen yeah we're gonna eat all
these [ __ ] look the point is
this PBR
I'm not gonna lie this was the craziest
sporting event I've ever seen in real
life now they invited you they were like
yo come no do it no I just want to go oh
really and then I hit them up
and then or Dove actually hit them up
and then no for real I had already we
already got tickets my wife's brother
was like yo we got to go to the PBR and
I was like I don't even know what the
[ __ ] the PBR is obviously I saw it or
heard of it I remember that movie eight
seconds when we were younger remember
that [ __ ] and then uh then Dove hit him
up and then we got to go to these like
dirt Suites and like you're just on the
dirt but when you're up close and you're
seeing a 2 000 pound Bull and then like
a five foot four inch Brazilian on top
of it because the Brazilians run this
[ __ ] that's another thing half of the
dudes are Brazilian and it's it's funny
because when the announcers are doing
the announcing they don't give a [ __ ]
about the Brazilians right they'll be
like you know Joe Buck from the grave
Hills Montana
Great again exactly like Jose Gusto from
Sao Paulo or some [ __ ] anyway
it was it was [ __ ] it was
unbelievable to see in person truly
unfucking real Disney person it's the
craziest thing I've ever seen I got to
go right on the [ __ ] things yeah we
saw that did you did everyone see the
bull stare right at Andrew's camera
right before this poor guy's about to go
eight seconds yup you pissed off that
bull I might have he looked right at the
camera I might have I saw one dude get
stomped out New York Nico posted a guy
they got like stomped on yeah yeah you
posted that yeah what happened to him he
gets hurt they all hurt bro
you get dude when you're in the little
cage right the the little cage before
they open it up and the thing starts
bucking right so the the rider goes on
it and you have to understand the cage
is like the size of the bowl if this
couch is probably bigger than the cage
so there's no room at all it's all made
by Steel the bull is 2 000 pounds if the
bull just moves its weight a little bit
to one side your leg is caught between
steel and bull and two thousands of
pounds of pressure is just leaning on it
so all these guys are just constantly
beating up constantly wrapped up like
they're they're all independent
contractors they just show up if they
make money they make money you if you
win that thing you get a belt buckle on
fifty thousand dollars how do you win
just staying on you there's around
everybody gets like a few tries and then
the top 12 after that go to the final
and then if you stay on for eight
seconds you're judged by how hard the
bull bucks and how well you stay on so
it's a bull don't bucket all you don't
get that many points it's almost like
diving where like that's not fair what
do you mean like what if you just got a
lazy bull well you choose you choose the
bowl uh that's why these [ __ ]
ain't playing around the dude who was in
who is in the lead after the first round
this guy named Bob Mitchell right he's
like 20 years old he got bucked off this
bull he gets first choice of bull so he
could choose the easiest bull he wants
and he goes up there and he goes and it
even like he's trying to sell the story
anything he just goes I want the rematch
whoa and you're like you could
wasn't dollars is Gonna Change obviously
your life in a significant way like and
he's like I want to run it back with
that [ __ ] that buck me off so
there's like some real like machismo
yeah into it and it was so [ __ ] cool
he ended up getting like third place he
got bucked off at the end yeah but he
went for it but he [ __ ] went third
place get money second place get money I
think I think everybody does but it's
like almost like poker where it's
fighting scale but the majority is that
first and like it ain't that much money
where no like these guys are in it
because they're [ __ ] in it they're
getting banged up every single time like
I mean it was [ __ ] what were the
other people like that were there uh
like the people in the stands yeah well
there's they they're they're the rodeo
clown I don't even know if it was right
to call him a clown or not but he is
wearing clown makeup yeah but like he's
the host and he's in the crowd doing
crowd work they're doing music cues like
he's [ __ ] entertaining the whole show
he's like it was really cool to see so
you got sold out Madison Square Garden
and he's doing his bits in between these
people trying to jump on a bull and ride
it and what kind of bits like like
there's music stuff he was flirting with
some girl in the audience and I asked
him I was like is this all like
pre-planned or he's he's like honestly
once we start it just goes and like
you know they're doing some song stuff
he was doing like a grease you know I
got chills they're multiplying with like
a girl who was like kind of flirting
with him from the crowd like I don't
know they just created this awesome
event and I want New Yorkers to get into
it I want them to do the cosplay [ __ ]
that I'm doing yeah where it's like I
mean it would make everybody more money
like those you think about that's what
I'm wondering what's the upside maybe
winning 50 000 however many events there
are a year even if you're really [ __ ]
good that's like a couple hundred
thousand well the winner of the whole
thing gets a million oh the one in the
whole year the whole year gets a million
but you don't even get the million
straight up you get a hundred thousand
dollars a year for 10 years
so it's like it's not that much money at
the top like there's much less dangerous
sports where you make nine figures Yep
this sounds so stupid no I'm wondering
what is the appeal for them because
there's something that draws them to it
hey Cowboys bro they're legit Cowboys
they are this is what they call people
doing yeah like that's the only thing I
can think of it's a cultural thing that
you're just not gonna get bro I was
talking to there's this one dude the
black the black dude that was there
there was two black dudes there there's
Ezekiel and then Keyshawn I was talking
one of them and he was kind of like John
that's a black name yo and he was
breaking it down and he was and I was
like is this you're like is this your
passion like whatever he's like to be
honest like I want a horse ranch
eventually I take this and I do a horse
I love horses I just kind of ended up
being good at this and it's a crazy
thing to find out like God forbid I'm
good at it yeah you know what I mean
like that has a tough way to make a
[ __ ] live what is like why do some of
them have helmets so that's the other
thing you have to wear a helmet if
you're born after the 90s oh hilarious
that's the way they made the rule and
this is why they made rule like that I
was talking to this guy Matt who was the
host and he goes the guys that were born
before that grew up their whole life
doing it without a helmet and because of
that their balance is much different he
goes yo two a two pound helmet changes
everything on a on a bull he's basically
like you have to feel every you ever
hear about how like uh people talk about
like F1 drivers where they can feel
every part of the car like what's
pulling what's pushing where the
overdraft is and all this you watch that
F1 show they're always saying exactly
what's wrong with the cars they're
driving I never know how they know and
it's just they're like one with the car
and that's the thing when you're with
these Bulls like you know exactly where
your body needs to be and they say that
those two pounds could mess it up and
there was a dude who was riding it and
head butts the [ __ ] Bull and his lip
explodes Brazilian guy like it no helmet
no helmet and he's allowed to because he
was born before the 90s that's so funny
it was like them hockey players remember
back in the day like when when helmets
were introduced for hockey players and
some of the old school dudes weren't
doing it oh that's so funny they still
do that with face masks and hockey now
yep visors yeah but it was just like it
was a crazy thing to see live and was it
New York
I was wondering because I went out one
day this week and I saw so many cowboy
hats and I was like oh is this like a
trend going on yeah no it's just but
that's that's what I want I want to turn
this weekend into okay
I want to turn this weekend into like
New York is you know Fleet Week when
everybody's all about the Navy comes
like I wish for a weekend everybody in
New York just it's Halloween but with
Country [ __ ] tablets exactly you get the
biggest country singers they do their
[ __ ] concerts at Giant Stadium
everybody goes to one of the days of the
PBR like just the whole country Embraces
it bro these dudes they were saying hi
to my wife they take their hat off to
say hi
tired
but low-key I was like yo got
but this move right here like that [ __ ]
is sexy dude because when they say to
the dude they go how you doing and then
they go yeah they do with the left hand
man like fire I mean like when they pray
they do national anthem they totally
they tell you take it out they go they
go gentlemen make sure you remove your
hats remove your shade or remove your
something remove your cover yeah yeah
and it was this cool baseball has this
where like there's cool culture built
into baseball outside of the sport
itself the fun the most fun part about
baseball is when they're pranking each
other and they Dugout and there's all
these cool like things that you're not
allowed to flip your bat because that's
insulting like yeah there's all this
cool culture built into this sport
that's been around forever and it's
basically dudes hanging out and when
dudes hang out it's fun these are all
dudes Cowboys hanging out the problem
with baseball is it's not one it's not
one time a year it comes to your city
and then you go cosplay and then make
the money like as annoying as you are
and all the New Yorkers would be if they
did that it makes them money and God
bless you need the money and when you
look at like the popularity of like
Yellowstone and like yeah three and I
just went through there there's so many
more people that are even like have
their their mind open to this lifestyle
yeah so which has been uh presented in a
very like romantic way even though it's
authentic is romantic right and it's
like you saw I even asked the people I
was like has it been different since
Yellowstone and the lady was like oh
really she was like oh yeah a noticeable
difference that's crazy